[موسيقى
] مرت ثلاث سنوات منذ
إطلاق air pods ويقول تيم كوك إن المبيعات
كانت هائلة الآن ، فنحن نحصل
على سماعات air pods Pro
سماعات أذن لاسلكية جديدة أعيد تصميمها بالكامل وهناك
أغلى بكثير ، فما الذي
يحصل عليه هذا السعر المرتفع  يمكنك إلغاء الضوضاء
ووضع شفافية جديد وجودة صوت أفضل ،
لذا فإن أحد أكبر الأشياء
في التصميم الجديد هو هذه
النصائح الصغيرة بمجرد وضعها في أذنيك ، فإنها
تخبرك ما إذا كانت الطريقة التي اخترتها
صغيرة ومتوسطة وكبيرة هي الأنسب
من المفترض أن تجعل أذنيك
تظل أكثر إحكامًا في أذنك ، لكن
لم يكن لدي الجهاز سوى لمدة 12 دقيقة تقريبًا
قبل أن أكون في رصيف مترو الأنفاق
وطار أحدهما بالفعل من أذني
وكاد يسقط على مسارات القطارات
يظهر على الرغم من أن
الحجم المحدد مصمم خصيصًا لي ، إلا أنه
لم يكن مناسبًا تمامًا ، إلا أن
ميزة إلغاء الضوضاء رائعة
لدي الآن ولا يمكنني سماع صفارات الإنذار
لا يمكنني سماع حركة المرور التي لا تتجاوز بضعة
أقدام  بعيدًا عني ، يبدو الأمر جيدًا حقًا
بالطبع هناك أوقات
لا ترغب فيها في ضبط العالم من
حولك ، لذلك أطلقت Apple
وضع الشفافية الذي يفعل ذلك بالضبط
حتى تتمكن من تشغيله بعدة طرق
يمكنك لمس الجانب  من جهازك أو
يمكنك الدخول إلى هاتفك في مركز التحكم ،
يمكنك التبديل بين
إلغاء الضوضاء أو وضع الشفافية ،
حيث تكون جودة الصوت عند الاستماع إلى الموسيقى
جيدة بشكل خاص ، ولكن عند إجراء
مكالمات هاتفية
، يبدو الأمر محببًا للغاية
أنت تجري مكالمة من خلال
مكبر صوت Bluetooth في سيارتك أو
كنت تستخدم مكبر الصوت بشكل عام ،
فهل يستحق الأمر 90 دولارًا إضافيًا ، من المهم أن
تتذكر أن أجهزة iPhone تأتي بالفعل مع
سماعات أذن مربوطة ، لذا فإن السدادات الهوائية بشكل عام
هي عنصر فاخر و  تعتبر air pods
Pro إصدارًا فاخرًا من منتج فاخر ،
فهل تحتاج إلى هذا المنتج على الأرجح
ولكن Apple قدمت بالتأكيد
جودة صوت مذهلة وإلغاء الضوضاء
[موسيقى]